NOTING.
ITEM NUMBER. THIRTY ONE SIXTEEN
THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE -- LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES IN CALIFORNIA ARE
TASKED WITH THE SOMETIMES
DIFFICULT TASK OF INVESTIGATING
INTERMITTENTLY BECAUSE OF A
KILLER ACCIDENTS.
THIS IS PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT
WHEN THE ACCIDENTS INVOLVED
SERIOUS DEATH OR INJURY
FORTUNATELY THAT MANY TOOLS
AVAILABLE TO THEM TO DO THEIR
JOBS -- NEW TOOL THAT THEY HAVE
IS DATA FROM THE EVENT DATA
RECORDER IN VEHICLES THIS IS A
DEVICE SIMILAR TO THE BLACK BOX
IN AIRCRAFT THAT RECORDS A
LIMITED SET OF PARAMETERS.
ABOUT WHAT WAS GOING ON WITH THE
CAR IN THE SECONDS BEFORE THE
CRASH IT TYPICALLY COVERS FIVE
SECONDS BEFORE TO ONE SECOND
AFTER AND RECORD SUCH PARAMETERS
AS THE SPEED -- THE POSITION OF
THE ACCELERATOR THE PERFORMANCE
OF THE VEHICLE SYSTEMS THINGS
LIKE THAT -- LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
EMPOWERED.
TO GET A SEARCH WARRANT TO GET
ACCESS INVOLUNTARILY TO THE
STATE IN THE EVENT OF A FELONY
INVESTIGATION -- MOST OF THE
OTHER TIMES IT IS CONSENSUAL
HOWEVER THERE ARE IMPORTANT
OCCASIONS WHERE'S CONSENT CANNOT
BE OBTAINED FOR EXAMPLE THAT
WHEN THERE'S A SOLE OCCUPANT OF
THE VEHICLE AND THAT.
OCCUPANT IS KILLED IN THE CRASH
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S NO ONE TO GIVE
CONSENT SO THIS BILL AB SIXTEEN
THIRTY EIGHT WOULD GIVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
INVESTIGATING THAT ACCIDENT.
THE PATHWAY TO GET ACCESS TO
THAT DATA IT WOULD -- REQUIRE
THEM TO GET A SEARCH WARRANTS
THEY WOULD HAVE TO CONVINCE A
JUDGE AS TO THE REASONABLE TEST
OF THEIR REQUEST AND THEY WOULD
BE ACT -- EMPOWER TO ACCESS ONLY
A VERY LIMITED NUMBER OF
PARAMETERS FROM THE OF THAT DATA
RECORDER IN THE VEHICLE.
I WANT TO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND YOUR STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH ME ON THE ON THIS
BILL THE AMENDMENTS THAT ARE
OUTLINED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS I THINK MAKES A GOOD
BILL MUCH BETTER THE NARROW THE
SCOPE.
AND THEY SAID WHAT I FEEL IS AN
APPROPRIATE BALANCE BETWEEN
PROTECTION FOR CONSUMER PRIVACY
ON THE ONE HAND AND THE NEED TO
INVESTIGATE THESE ACCIDENTS ON
THE OTHER SO.
I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MIGHT
HAVE.
YOU HAVE ANY WITNESSES OR HERE
FOR TECHNICAL ADVICE OR MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS LARRY MORSE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION.
EXISTING LAW DENIES AN OFFICER
INVESTIGATING A MISDEMEANOR
ACCIDENT WHICH DEATH OR SERIOUS
BODILY INJURY HAS OCCURRED.
THE ABILITY TO SEEK A SEARCH
WARRANT TO RECOVER THE EVENT
DATA RECORDER THE SO CALLED
AUTOMOTIVE BLACK BOX.
IN ORDER TO DETERMINE THE CAUSE
OF AN AUTOMOBILE ACCIDENT.
IT'S A LITTLE LIKE DENYING
INVESTIGATORS ACCESS TO A BLACK
BOX IN AN AIRLINE CRASH LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS TASKED WITH
INVESTIGATING MOTOR VEHICLE
ACCIDENTS INVOLVING DEATH OR
SERIOUS BODILY INJURY.
DETERMINING THE CAUSE OF SUCH
ACCIDENTS AND GATHERING EVIDENCE
TO DETERMINE IF A MISDEMEANOR
PROSECUTION IS APPROPRIATE.
ET OUR DATA IS SCIENTIFIC
EVIDENCE IT CAN BE CRUCIAL TO
UNDERSTANDING THE PHYSICAL
EVIDENCE.
CAN CORROBORATE TRADITIONAL
ACCIDENT RECONSTRUCTION
CALCULATIONS AND IS ESPECIALLY
USEFUL WHEN NO WITNESSES ARE
AVAILABLE OR THERE IS A CONFLICT
IN THEIR STATEMENTS.
AB SIXTEEN THIRTY EIGHT IS
NARROWLY DRAFTED AND APPLIES
ONLY TO ACCIDENTS INVOLVING
DEATH OR SERIOUS BODILY INJURY.
DOES NOT INFRINGE IN ANY WAY ON
A PRIVACY RIGHT AND LIKE ALL
SEARCH WARRANTS REQUIRES
JUDICIAL APPROVAL.
THIS BILL IS NECESSARY BECAUSE
CURRENTLY NO SUCH RIGHT TO SEEK
A SEARCH WARRANT EXISTS WITH
REGARD TO A MISDEMEANOR.
IT'S BEEN SUGGESTED THAT THIS
INFORMATION CAN ALREADY BE
OBTAINED THROUGH A SUBPOENA.
HOWEVER SUBPOENAS OR ISSUED.
AFTER CRIMINAL CASES ARE FILED A
SEARCH WARRANT IS AN
INVESTIGATIVE TOOL BEFORE FILING
ONE THAT IS USED TO DETERMINE
WHETHER CRIMINAL CHARGES OR EVEN
APPROPRIATE.
IN ADDITION TO ASSISTING IN THE
INVESTIGATION OF A POTENTIAL
MISDEMEANOR PROSECUTION THE ET
ARE BLACK BOX CAN PROVIDE
ESSENTIAL EVIDENCE IN CIVIL
LAWSUITS.
FILED AGAINST DRIVERS OR
GOVERNMENTAL ENTITIES THE BOTTOM
LINE IS THAT SOME OF THE MOST
CRUCIAL AND SCIENTIFICALLY
RELIABLE EVIDENCE REGARDING
COLLISION CAUSATION IS
INACCESSIBLE TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
DUE TO THIS CURRENT GAP.
IN THE LOG AB SIXTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT WILL CLOSE THAT GAP AND
PROVIDE LAW ENFORCEMENT
INVESTIGATORS A VALUABLE
SCIENTIFIC TOOL TO COMPLETE
THEIR INVESTIGATIONS AND THE
MOST THOROUGH AND PROFESSIONAL
MANNER.
CDA URGES DRIVE OF THANK YOU
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD EVENING MR TERRON MEMBERS
SAW KATHY SURE FOR THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA WE RESPECTFULLY MUST
OPPOSE AB.
SIXTEEN THIRTY EIGHT CALIFORNIA
LAWN SEARCH WARRANTS BOUNCED
BALANCES TWO VERY IMPORTANT
INTERESTS OF INTEREST THE
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO BE
PROTECTED FROM UNREASONABLE
GOVERNOR GOVERNMENT SEARCHES AND
SEIZURES.
AND THE NEED FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO BE ABLE TO INVESTIGATE CRIMES
ONE WAY CALIFORNIA LAW DOES THIS
IS BY SETTING A GENERAL RULE
THAT A WARRANT CAN BE SOUGHT
WHEN THE EVIDENCE TO BE SEIZED
AS EVIDENCE OF A FELONY.
THERE IS NO GENERAL PROVISION
ALLOWING ISSUANCE OF A SEARCH
WARRANT WHERE WHERE THE THING TO
BE SEIZED AS EVIDENCE OF A
LESSER CRIME.
AB SIXTEEN THIRTY EIGHT WOULD
ALLOW ISSUANCE OF A WARRANT FOR
INFORMATION FROM A VEHICLE'S
RECORDING DEVICE THE CONSTITUTES
AN AND EVIDENCE OF ANY PUBLIC
OFFENSE INVOLVING A MOTOR
VEHICLE.
RESULTING IN DEATH OR BODILY
INJURY I DO WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT THIS IS NOT ONLY
APPLICABLES -- TO AS SINGLE
VEHICLE ACCIDENTS -- THEY COULD
BE SOMETHING WHERE THERE IS MORE
THAN ONE VEHICLE INVOLVED IT
COULD BE A SEARCH WARRANT -- FOR
THE RECORDER FROM THE CAR WHERE
THERE'S NO SUSPICION AT ALL THAT
THAT THE DRIVER OF THAT CAR WAS
AT FAULT -- BY ALLOWING THE
ISSUANCE OF A WARRANT FOR THE
EXTENSIVE INFORMATION AVAILABLE
FROM THE VEHICLE RECORDING
DEVICE AND WE DO APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR WORKING WITH US TODAY TO
NARROW WHAT WHAT EVIDENCE WOULD
BE.
ALLOWED TO BE SOUGHT BUT
NONETHELESS THERE THERE STILL IS
EXTENSIVE INFORMATION THAT YOU
CAN GET FROM THESE RECORDING
DEVICES -- FOR NON FELONY
OFFENSE AB SIXTEEN THIRTY EIGHT
UPSETS THE BALANCE BETWEEN THE
INTERESTS OF CALIFORNIANS IN
HAVING THEIR PERSONAL
INFORMATION PROTECTED FROM
GOVERNMENT SEARCHES AND SEIZURES --
AND INDEED THE NEED OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO INVESTIGATE
CRIMES -- IT IS CERTAINLY OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE ARE
OTHER MEANS FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO GET ON THIS KIND OF
INFORMATION OUT THERE THERE MAY
NOT BE A CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION
AT ALL AND CERTAINLY.
IN CASES WHERE THERE IS NO NO.
INTENT TO PROSECUTE THERE ARE
WAYS TO GET INFORMATION.
FROM THE VEHICLE SUCH AS THROUGH
A SUBPOENA -- SO WHEN WHEN A
DRIVERS KILLED IN AN ACCIDENT
AND THERE IS NO CRIMINAL
PROSECUTION LAW ENFORCEMENT
SHOULD BE ABLE TO SUBPOENA THAT
INFORMATION FROM THE VEHICLES
DATA RECORDER WE ASK FOR YOUR NO
VOTE.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I MOVE THE BILL ESTERMAN
SECOND.
AND THE QUESTION.
SO IS IT TRUE THAT THE BILL
WOULD ALLOW FOR SEARCH WARRANTS
FOR NON CRIMINAL ACTIVITY -- I
WOULD BELIEVE THAT STATE CASES
IS NOT.
WILL IT WOULD ALLOW SEARCH
WARRANTS FOR A A PUBLIC OFFENSE
WHAT.
BY MAKE -- THE WAY THIS MOST
OFTEN COMES UP YOU HAVE THEY'RE
THE WORST CASES OF AND MANY
ROUTE INSTANCES OF PROSECUTORS
DEAL WITH.
A MISDEMEANOR -- VEHICULAR
MANSLAUGHTER IN WHICH IT'S OF
THERE BUT FOR THE GRACE OF GOD
THING SOMEBODY'S INATTENTIVE FOR
A PERIOD OF TIME -- REACHING
OVER AND YOU KNOW DOING
SOMETHING AND DRIVES OFF THE
ROTOR CAUSES A COLLISION.
OR SOMETHING.
THAT'S A THAT'S POTENTIALLY A
MISDEMEANOR ENABLE IT YOU'RE
YOU'RE REQUIRED TO OBSERVE A
CERTAIN -- CAUTION THE THE
ORDINARY PERSON WOULD WHILE
YOU'RE OPERATING A MOTOR VEHICLE --
THE THIS WOULD ALLOW AN
INVESTIGATOR TO EVALUATE WHETHER
THERE WAS SOMETHING GOING ON
WITH THE CAR SOMETHING ELSE
HAPPENING IN ORDER TO DETERMINE
WHETHER CRIMINAL CHARGES IT'S A
MISDEMEANOR IN THIS CASE WOULD
EVEN BE APPROPRIATE.
WE FILE MISDEMEANORS PROSECUTORS
FILE MISDEMEANORS EVERY DAY --
UNFORTUNATELY IN MISDEMEANOR --
VEHICULAR MANSLAUGHTER CASES --
BECAUSE A PERSON WAS AN
ATTENTIVE ON THE ROAD AND
SOMEONE DIED OR WAS SERIOUSLY
INJURED AS A RESULT OF IT.
THIS IS JUST AN INVESTIGATIVE
TOOL -- TO ALLOW AN OFFICER --
TO MAKE A THOROUGH INVESTIGATION
USING THE BEST AVAILABLE
EVIDENCE WHICH WOULD OBVIOUSLY
BE THE THE BLACK BOX TO
DETERMINE IN A VERY NARROW FIVE
SECOND PERIOD WHETHER ANYTHING
WAS GOING ON WITH THE CAR.
THAT COULD BE A CONTRIBUTING OR
EXONERATING FACTOR.
DOES IT IS TO THEY SO YOU DOES
NOT CONCERNING THIS COULD SERVE
AFTER SERVE OPEN THE DOOR IN A
WAY THAT.
CAN BE VERY CONCERNING THE FACT
THAT THEY CAN BE A SURCHARGE FOR
NON CRIMINAL ACTIVITY.
YES CERTAINLY I THINK THAT THAT
IS A CONCERN -- I I ALSO
QUESTION.
IF IT IS LIMITED TO CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY THEN I'M NOT SURE IF IT
GETS OUT THE SITUATION OF THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OLD OBERNOLTE
HAS.
HAS CITED -- BUT YEAH WE WE
CERTAINLY WOULD HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT ANY -- SEARCH WARRANT
BEING USED IT WHETHER IT THERE
IS NO -- CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION
INVOLVED IN AGAIN I YOU KNOW I I
I CERTAINLY AM NO EXPERT IN HOW
LAW ENFORCEMENT INVESTIGATES--
INCIDENCES.
WHERE THERE IS NO CRIME
SUSPECTED BUT BUT I THINK THAT
THEY DO HAVE MEANS OTHER THAN
SEARCH WARRANTS AT THEIR?
AT THEIR DISPOSAL TO GET
INFORMATION OUT TO TO BE CLEAR
WE DISAGREE WITH THE ACLU'S
ASSESSMENT THAT A SUBPOENA COULD
BE USED IN THOSE KINDS OF
CIRCUMSTANCES.
THE INFORMATION THAT WE HAVE IS
THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT REALLY HAS
NO TOOLS WHEN THERE'S A SOLE
OCCUPANT OF VEHICLE THE HE'S THE
OWNER OF THE VEHICLE.
AND UNFORTUNATELY IS DECEASED AS
A RESULT OF THE ACCIDENT.
IN THE IN THE SITUATION YOU
DESCRIBED WOULDN'T IT BE
POSSIBLE TO GET A SEARCH WARRANT
IF THERE'S PROBABLE CAUSE IF YOU
WERE ABLE TO SHOW PROBABLE CAUSE
OUT IN A MISDEMEANOR NOT IN AS
SOON AS YOU CAN ONLY DO A
PROBABLE.
HEARING IN A BALLOT A
MISDEMEANOR THE SUBPOENA CAN
ONLY BE ISSUED AFTER THIS IS
WHERE WE DISAGREE WITH OUR
FRIENDS FROM THE DEAL YOU ONLY
AFTER A CASE HAS BEEN FILED --
SEARCH WARRANT IS AN
INVESTIGATIVE TOOL TO HELP YOU
FIGURE OUT WHAT HAPPENED RIGHT.
SO I GUESS MY CONCERN IS THAT
WE'RE NOT ASKING FOR ANY
PROBABLE CAUSE STANDARD WHICH WE
HAVE IN FELONY SETTING IS THAT
RIGHT ABSOLUTELY WOULD HAVE
PROBABLE CAUSE BECAUSE IT'S GOT
TO GO TO A JUDGE.
YOU KNOW WHAT WOULD A JUDGE AND
THE JUDGE WOULD DO A PROBLEM
BECAUSE YOU'RE ONLY ONE YOU HAVE
GOT BRING AFFIDAVIT OF PROBABLE
CAUSE TO THE JUDGE HE WHICH SHE
WOULD HAVE TO REVIEW IT AND
DETERMINE THERE WAS PROBABLE
CAUSE. FOR ISSUANCE OF THE
SEARCH WARRANT GOT THANK YOU FOR
CLARIFICATION.
YES MISTER LACKEY I THINK THERE
MIGHT BE A DISAGREEMENT ON WHAT
QUALIFIES AS A CRIMINAL OFFENSE
TO BECAUSE IT.
IN THE BILL IT TALKS ABOUT A
PUBLIC OFFENSE WHICH CAL ALSO
INCLUDE JUST A FRACTION LIKE
RUNNING A RED LIGHT.
AND SO MANY OF THESE INSTANCES
YOU HAVE.
AND AND MANSLAUGHTER CASES YOU
HAVE TO HAVE A DEATH.
AND MANY OF THESE CASES ARE JUST
VERY VERY SERIOUS INJURIES AND
ONE THING THAT.
THIS IS NOT GOING TO BE USED.
EXCESSIVELY BECAUSE IT IT TAKES
A HIGH LEVEL OF EXPERTISE AND
UNDERSTANDING TO EVEN.
COLLECT THIS DATA AND UNDERSTAND
AND INTERPRET WHAT IT WHAT IT
SAYS -- THIS EVENT DATA RECORDER
IS.
EVIDENTIARY VALUE THAT SHOULD BE
ACCESSED AND THERE'S THERE'S
PROTECTION OF PRIVACY BECAUSE
YOU'RE HAVING THE JUDICIAL
REVIEW LIKE I WOULD HOPE WE ALL
WOULD TRUST THE JUDGE WOULD MAKE.
THE APPROPRIATE ASSESSMENT OF
WHETHER THERE'S PROBABLE CAUSE.
TO ACCESS THIS INFORMATION AND
SO I THINK THERE'S A BUILT IN
PROTECTION THERE AND I THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
BECAUSE ACCURACY INVESTIGATIONS
ARE SOCIAL PIVOTAL AND NOT JUST
IN.
OF MANSLAUGHTER CASES RIGHT A
LOT OF TIMES YOU HAVE PEOPLE WHO
HAVE.
LOST FUNCTION AND WHO HAVE LOST --
THE ABILITY TO LIVE A NORMAL
LIFE BECAUSE SOMEONE HAS ACTED
INAPPROPRIATELY BUT YET THEY
HAVE A VERBAL DEFENSE.
AND LEST WE HAVE PHYSICAL
DEFENSE TO REFUTE THAT BECAUSE
VERY VERY DIFFICULT TO ARRIVE AT
A POINT OF JUSTICE AND SO I'VE I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BRING THIS
FORWARD.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
YOU MAY CLOSE MISS OBERNOLTE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SO I AM
VERY SENSITIVE TO THE NEED TO
PROTECT CONSUMER PRIVACY AND THE
CONSUMERS INFORMATION IN.
THE EVENT DATA RECORDER AND
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE CRAFTED THIS
SO NARROWLY.
IN SUCH A A VERY LIMITED WAY SO
TO BE CLEAR YOU'D HAVE TO OBTAIN
A SEARCH WARRANT WHICH MEANS
CONVINCING A JUDGE.
THAT.
THE NEED FOR THE INFORMATION WAS
ACCURATE -- AND AND WE HAVE
NARROWED THE SCOPE OF THE BILL
TO ONLY CERTAIN PARAMETERS OF
THE EDR SO THIS WOULD NOT BE A
FISHING EXPEDITION. FOR PEOPLE
TO GO THROUGH OTHER PERSONAL
INFORMATION THAT MIGHT BE STORED
ON THIS THIS IS JUST A VERY
RELEVANT DATA IN THE SECONDS
LEADING UP TO AND IMMEDIATELY
FOLLOWING THE COLLISION SO THIS
WOULD BE.
I THINK A VALUABLE NEEDED TOOL
AND I RICH RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN IPHONE.
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE AND I
I BELIEVE I WAS A NO AND THEN --
HE TOOK SOME AMENDMENTS AND THEN
WE GOT SOME.
SOME MORE INFORMATION REALLY
ABOUT.
WHAT?
WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT NOW
AND THAT'S WHY I WENT TO A NON --
IN -- IN A BECAUSE I'M NOT I
WOULD LOVE TO HAVE.
THIS FULLY BAKED BEFORE WE WE
LEFT AND I AM NOT SURE.
WITH THE OBJECTIONS OF THE OF
THE OPPOSITION IF WE COULD HAVE
GOTTEN THERE RIGHT NOW.
UP AND SO -- I HONESTLY BELIEVES
TWO OF THE TWO SIDES GOT
TOGETHER.
AND FIGURED OUT HOW TO USE.
THE SEARCH WOMAN'S WARS DID NOT.
GET TOO INTRUSIVE -- IT WOULD BE
ABLE TO FIGURE IT OUT BUT
BECAUSE OF TIME AND IT'S JUST
BEEN REALLY.
DIFFICULT -- SO WITH THAT A CALL
FOR A VOTE.
MISTER CHAIR IF I MIGHT A NICE
IT AT I'M SIDE IT'LL ALLOW.
ALL RIGHT.
ANYONE ELSE AND IS NOT USED TO
SEVEN BE AS CONSISTENT AS
POSSIBLE.
OTHERWISE I'D HAVE WHEN YOUR
COLLEAGUES COMING AFTER ME FOR
CUTTING THEM OFF [inaudible]
OF ON A. B. SIXTEEN THIRTY EIGHT
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE PRIVACY AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER.
JOHN SO YOU'RE NOT VOTING LACKEY
AYE LACKEY AYE BARRICADE HAN CAN
GO NEXT.
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN ELEVEN TWENTY
ONE BY OUR QUE HAN.
FIREARMS PROHIBITED [inaudible]
PERSONS.
WE'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT
PROHIBITIVE.
THE LAST TWO DAYS.
HELLO CHAIR IN COMMITTEE.
I WILL KEEP THIS AS BRIEF AS
POSSIBLE BECAUSE I KNOW HOW LONG
YOU'VE BEEN HERE ADD TâM
PRESENTING AB ELEVEN TWENTY ONE
AND BUILD THE BALANCES TREATMENT
NEEDS OF A DEFENDANT WITH PUBLIC
SAFETY NEEDS OF OUR COMMUNITY.
AN SP TWO FIFTEEN SENATOR BELLS
BILL WAS SIGNED INTO LAW
CREATING MENTAL HEALTH DIVERSION
PROGRAMS.
PROGRAMS ALLOW INDIVIDUALS WHO
COMMITTED CRIMES IN WHICH THEY
ARE CERTIFIED.
IN WHICH THEY'RE CERTIFIED TO
SUFFER FROM MENTAL ILLNESS --
AND THE MENTAL THIS IS A FACTOR
CRIME TO ENTER INTO THESE
PROGRAMS INSTEAD OF THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
AND THESE PROGRAMS ARE AN
IMPORTANT PART OF OUR SYSTEM AND
ALLOWING PEOPLE TO GET TREATMENT
OUTSIDE OF THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM [inaudible]
BUT LIKE OTHER DIVERSION
PROGRAMS IN OUR SYSTEM IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE LOOK AT THE
QUESTION OF WHETHER THE
INDIVIDUALS IN THESE PROGRAM
SHOULD HAVE A RIGHT. TO HAVE
THEIR FIREARMS WALL GOING
THROUGH THE PROGRAM.
CURRENTLY INDIVIDUALS WITH
MENTAL ILLNESS HAVE INTERACTION
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT SUCH AS FOR
MENTAL HEALTH EVALUATION THEY'RE
PROHIBITED FROM POSSESSING
FIREARMS FOR FIVE YEARS.
ALSO ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
COMMUNICATES THREATS OF VIOLENCE
TO A PSYCHOTHERAPIST ARE ALSO
PROHIBITED FROM POSSESSING
FIREARMS OR FIVE YEARS AND
UNFORTUNATELY CURRENT LAW DOES
NOT REQUIRE THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO ENTER THIS MENTAL HEALTH
DIVERSION PROGRAM. TO SURRENDER
THEIR FIRE ARMS.
AB ELEVEN TWENTY ONE WOULD MAKE
THE PROHIBITION OF FIREARMS AS A
CONDITION FOR ENTERING THE
MENTAL HEALTH DIVERSION PROGRAMS.
AT THE END OF THE SUCCESSFUL
COMPLETION OF THE PROGRAM AN
INDIVIDUAL MAY PETITION THE
COURT TO GET HIS OR HER FIRE ARM
BACK WITH ME TODAY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB.
ELEVEN TWENTY ONE IS LD LEWIS
ASSISTANT DISTRICT ATTORNEY FROM
ALAMEDA COUNTY.
GOOD EVENING GOOD EVENING.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE MY NAME IS L.
D. LEWIS AND I'M AN ASSISTANT
DISTRICT ATTORNEY WITH THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE.
AND THE HEAD OF THE MENTAL
HEALTH UNIT AND I'VE BEEN --
WORKING IN MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
FOR NEARLY A DECADE -- AND I'M
ONE OF THE SPONSORS WE ARE ONE
OF THE SPONSORS FOR ELEVEN
TWENTY ONE I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
DISTRICT ATTORNEY -- NANCY
O'MALLEY I'M HERE TODAY TO ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
FOR REQUIRING INDIVIDUALS AND
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS AND CHARGED
WITH CRIMINAL OFFENSES TO
RELINQUISH DANGEROUS AND DEADLY
WEAPONS WHILE THEY UNDERGO
TREATMENT -- IN THE MENTAL
HEALTH DIVERSION PROGRAM THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENT IS SOUND
PUBLIC POLICY AND INCREASES BOTH
THE PERSONAL SAFETY OF THE
INDIVIDUAL ENTERING TREATMENT AS
WELL AS PUBLIC SAFETY.
AND NOW THERE'S A LOT OF
LITERATURE OUT THERE INCLUDING --
FROM THE HARVARD PUBLIC HEALTH --
SCHOOL THAT TALKS ABOUT -- THE
SERIOUS THREAT FOR SUICIDES WHEN
INDIVIDUALS -- HAVE FIRE ARMS
IT'S THE MOST LETHAL -- WEAPON
THAT AN INDIVIDUAL CAN HAVE WHEN
THEY'RE MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS.
OF A NUMBER OF STUDIES HAVE
INDICATED THAT ONE LETHAL MEANS
ARE MADE LESS AVAILABLE -- LESS
DEADLY OR LESS DEADLY SUICIDE
RATES BY THAT METHOD DECLINE AND
FREQUENTLY SUICIDE RATES OVERALL
DECLINE -- ACCORDING TO THE
RESEARCH THAT'S OUT THERE -- THE
BECAUSE OF THE LEASE THE RATE OF
SUICIDE IS BOTH THE EASE OF USE
IN THE ACCESSIBILITY OF THE
WEAPON.
THAT THE INDIVIDUALS ARE USING
TO HARM THEMSELVES.
THIS LEGISLATION WOULD REMOVE
EXCESS ABILITY TO DANGEROUS OR
DEADLY WEAPONS AT A CRITICAL
TIME WHEN INDIVIDUALS ARE
SUFFERING FROM SYMPTOMS OF THEIR
SEVERE MENTAL ILLNESS -- SO
SEVERE THAT THEY'RE ACTUALLY
COMMITTING CRIMINAL OFFENSES.
IN EVERY INSTANCE WHERE
INDIVIDUALS ARE A MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS UNDER EXISTING LAW ACCESS
TO DANGEROUS OR DEADLY WEAPONS
IS PROHIBITED.
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE DEEMED NOT
COMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL ARE
REQUIRED TO RELINQUISH THEIR
DANGEROUS OR DEADLY WEAPONS.
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE COMMITTED
NO OFFENSES BUT ARE COMMITTED TO
THE HOSPITAL DUE TO ACUTE MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS PURSUANT TO
WELFARE AND INSTITUTIONS CODE.
FIFTY ONE FIFTY ARE ALSO
REQUIRED TO RELINQUISH THEIR
DANGEROUS OR DEADLY WEAPONS THIS
AMENDMENT WOULD BRING THE MENTAL
HEALTH DIVERSION Là INTO
ALIGNMENT WITH CURRENT PUBLIC
POLICY IN EXISTING LAW. FOR A
DECADE THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE HAS
BEEN ENGAGED IN FORMAL MENTAL
HEALTH DIVERSION FOR
MISDEMEANORS.
UNDER THE NEW MENTAL HEALTH
DIVERSION Là VIOLENT OFFENSES
ARE NOW ELIGIBLE FOR MENTAL
HEALTH DIVERSION.
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE COMMITTED
DANGEROUS OFFENSES SUCH AS
FELONY DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ASSAULT
WITH GREAT BODILY INJURY.
AND BATTERY WITH SERIOUS INJURY
ARE ALL ELIGIBLE FOR MENTAL
HEALTH DIVERSION UNDER THE
CURRENT LAW.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE A SEVERE
STABBING CASE WERE GREAT BODILY
INJURY IS ALLEGED WHICH IS
PENDING MENTAL HEALTH DIVERSION
IN MY COUNTY -- AB ELEVEN TWENTY
ONE WOULD REDUCE THE RISK OF
HARM TO OTHERS IN PARTICULAR --
IN SERIOUS FELONY CASES OF
DIVERSION AS GRANITE.
THE MENTAL HEALTH DIVERSION LAW
CURRENTLY REQUIRES THE
INDIVIDUAL THE INDIVIDUALS
MENTAL DISORDER WAS A
SIGNIFICANT FACTOR IN THE
COMMISSION OF THE CHARGED
OFFENSE.
THIS MEANS THAT THE CRIMINAL
CONDUCT THE INDIVIDUAL EXHIBIT
EXHIBIT -- THEIR MENTAL ILLNESS
IS A DRIVING FACTOR IN THE
COMMISSION OF THAT CONDUCT.
NOW WE HAVE LIMITED MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES IN OUR JAIL ONE
ALAMEDA COUNTY AND WE DO NOT
INVOLUNTARY.
MEDICATE IMAGE INMATES WHILE
THEY'RE IN CUSTODY.
THIS LEGISLATION WOULD ENSURE
THAT IS INDIVIDUALS ARE STEPPING
DOWN -- OUT OF CUSTODY AND INTO
TREATMENT THAT THEY WOULD DO SO
IN THE SAFEST MANNER POSSIBLE
BOTH RISK FOR THEMSELVES AND FOR
OTHERS.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
THIS IS NOT A LIFETIME BAN
BUDGET A JUDGE CAN RETURN
DANGEROUS AND DEADLY WEAPONS TO
INDIVIDUALS AFTER SUCCESSFUL
COMPLETION OF MENTAL HEALTH
DIVERSION.
AND IF THE COURTS DEEM THAT IT'S
SAFE TO DO SO WE HOPE THAT YOU
WILL SUPPORT THIS COMMONSENSE
CHANGE TO THE MENTAL HEALTH
DIVERSION LAW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
AND ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
CHECK IN.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
GOOD EVENING [inaudible]
EVENING NOW [inaudible]
THING RIGHT.
AND FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO DON'T
KNOW -- LD AND I FOUGHT.
AGAINST ONE ANOTHER.
AND I THOUGHT I'D RETIRED.
BUT THAT BEING SAID -- THANK YOU
I REALLY WANT TO REACH OUT AND
THANK THE CHAIR AND YOUR STAFF --
WE APPRECIATE THE PROFFERED
AMENDMENT AND WE THOUGHT THAT
WAS VERY REASONABLE THAT SOMEONE
WOULD GIVE UP THEIR WEAPONS FOR
THE DURATION OF THE MENTAL
HEALTH -- DIVERSION.
WHAT IS NOT REASONABLE ABOUT AB
ELEVEN TWENTY ONE IS THAT
BASICALLY IT WOULD TREAT
CALIFORNIANS WHO ACCEPT MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT?
AND HAVE NEVER COMMITTED A CRIME
SOMEONE WHO HAS NO CRIMINAL
RECORD MORE HARSHLY THAN THOSE
WHO REFUSE MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT.
AND ARE SUBSEQUENTLY CONVICTED
OF A CRIMINAL OFFENSE.
IN THAT RESPECT AB TWO ELEVEN
TWENTY ONE UNDERMINES EXISTING
LAW IN ITS GOAL TO KEEP PEOPLE
FROM SUFFERING THE LONG TERM
CONSEQUENCES OF THE CRIMINAL
CONVICTION WHILE PROMOTING
PUBLIC SAFETY.
SO FOR EXAMPLE IN ALAMEDA COUNTY.
ALTHOUGH -- MISS LEWIS HAS TOLD
YOU ABOUT SOME PEOPLE WHO HAVE
COMMITTED VIOLENT OFFENSES.
YOU MIGHT ALSO FIND PEOPLE WHO
HAVE COMMITTED NONVIOLENT
OFFENSES SHOPLIFTING WHATEVER
AND THEY MIGHT BE ELIGIBLE FOR
MENTAL HEALTH DIVERSION.
AND THERE ARE A NUMBER OF MENTAL
ILLNESSES THAT DO NOT HAVE IN
THE APPRECIABLE RECORD. FOR
VIOLENCE -- CLINICAL DEPRESSION
WE DON'T HEAR TOO MUCH ABOUT
PEOPLE GOING OUT AND COMMITTING
VIOLENT OFFENSES WHO ARE
CLINICALLY DEPRESSED.
AND THESE INDIVIDUALS IF THEY
CHOOSE TO ACCEPT DIVERSION ARE
ACCEPTING WHAT IN MOST URBAN
COUNTIES WOULD BE.
ON A MUCH MORE ONEROUS COURSE
THEN IF THEY JUST ACCEPTED WHAT
WOULD BE THE TYPICAL PLEA
BARGAIN.
IN OAKLAND OR LA WHICH WOULD BE
CREDIT FOR TIME SERVED.
PROBATION AND OUTDOOR.
AND IF THEY ACCEPTED THAT.
THEY WOULDN'T HAVE ANY MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT.
THEY WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN THE
PROHIBITION AGAINST WEAPONS.
THEY JUST BE GOING ON ABOUT
THEIR BUSINESS [inaudible]
SO.
THE VERSION MENTAL HEALTH TO
VERSION WAS PASSED WITH THE GOAL
OF TRYING TO KEEP PEOPLE OUT OF
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. TO
DEAL WITH PEOPLE WHO ARE
SUFFERING FROM UNDERLYING MENTAL
ILLNESS AND TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
WERE ALL SAFE.
THIS BILL THREATENS THE
PARTICIPATION.
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T JUST ON BAND
FIRE ARMS.
IT BANS ALL DEADLY WEAPONS.
SO FOR EXAMPLE A KITCHEN KNIFE
COULD BE A DEADLY WEAPON RIGHT
YOU GO INTO YOUR KITCHEN AND YOU
PULL OUT A BUTCHER KNIFE THAT'S
A DOUBLE WEAPON -- IT COULD BE
[inaudible]
SO.
AND THEN.
THE PART OF THE THAT YOU KNOW
THE PART THAT THE EMPHASIS THE
PROFFERED AMENDMENT MADE A LOT
OF SENSE IT WOULD BE.
WHILE SOMEONE WAS ON DIVERSION
THEY WOULD GIVE UP THEIR WEAPONS.
BUT IN THIS SCENARIO UNDER THE
WAY THAT AB ELEVEN TWENTY ONE IS
WRITTEN RIGHT NOW.
IT IS A PERMANENT BAN.
UNLESS YOU GO BACK TO THE JUDGE.
AND THE JUDGE THEN IS FACED WITH
THE THE MAKING A DECISION.
WELL THIS PERSON HAS SOUTH SOUTH
FULLY COMPLETED DIVERSION BUT
THEY HAVE A HISTORY OF MENTAL
ILLNESS.
AM I GOING TO BE THE JUDGE TO
RETURN THEIR GUN.
LIFT THE BAN ON DEADLY WEAPONS.
SO ONCE THAT HAPPENS YOU'RE
GOING TO CREATE IN MANY PLACES A
BARK TO PEOPLE PARTICIPATING IN
THE DIVERSION PROGRAM.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS FOR
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR NO VOTE.
THANK YOU OR ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
LACKEY IT LOOKS LIKE.
CAN THE ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
BAUER-KAHAN.
CAN YOU JUST -- TALK ABOUT THE
POINT THAT WAS RAISED THAT
KITCHEN KNIVES WOULD NOT BE ABLE
TO BE USED AS IT IS IT NARROWLY
FOCUSED ON FIREARMS OR IS IT
DEADLY WEAPONS IN GENERAL AND
CAN YOU JUST.
YES THANK YOU I AM SO ONE OF
THINGS I DO WANT TO SAY AND
RESPECT AND WHAT IF THE I ALSO
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE AND
THE CHAIR FOR WORKING WITH US ON
THIS BILL -- GIVEN THE PRESSURE
FOR TIME AND SOME COMPLICATIONS
I SHOULD POINT OUT THAT BOTH LA
COUNTY AND SAN DIEGO COUNTY RD.
THIS IS THEIR PRACTICE -- AND SO
ONE OF THE COMPLICATING FACTORS
AS WE NEED TO ENSURE WE WRITE A
BILL THAT ALLOWS THEM TO
CONTINUE THE PRACTICES THAT THEY
SEE FIT -- AND SO THAT'S PART OF
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO WORK
THROUGH IN THE BILL WHICH I
THINK WE ALL AGREE ON I THINK I
CAN SAY BUT MAYBE I SHOULDN'T
SPEAK -- SO -- SO WE ARE WORKING
ON CONTINUE AMENDMENTS ONE OF
WHICH IS WE DON'T INTEND FOR
THIS TO BE A LIFETIME BAN THE
OTHER I'M IS THAT IT IS INTENDED
TO BE ON FOCUSED ON FIRE ARMS
AND IF IT WERE TO INCLUDE SUCH
OTHER WEAPONS THAT'S AN
AMENDMENT I WOULD HAPPILY.
TAKE IF IT INCLUDES KITCHEN
KNIVES OKAY THANKS ALL THAT FOR
THE MR QUIRK.
I WISH SHE'D TAKEN THE CHAIRS
MAN MEANT BUT I'LL VOTE FOR
TODAY BUT TAP PLEASE.
I KNOW YOU WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
ON IT.
YOU ARE MY SEAT MAY -- AS THE
MOTION BEEN SECONDED.
OKAY YES I WAS WORKING KNOW
WHERE TO FIND ME AND I. S. AND
OUR OWN CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS
BILL GOING FORWARD AS I HAVE
DISCUSSED WITH THE CHAIR.
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
AND I BELIEVE MR LACKEY SAID.
MISS WICKS.
ADDRESS THIS POINT.
OKAY YOU MAY CLOSE.
SO I THIS IS AN IMPORTANT STEP
IN ENSURING THAT -- OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE SAFE FROM ALL
SORTS OF GUN VIOLENCE AND LIKE I
SAID WE HAVE TO COUNTIES IN THIS
LARGE COUNTIES IN THE STATE THAT
ALREADY DO THIS AND I THINK IT
WOULD MAKE A LOT OF SENSE FOR US
TO EXTEND IT AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING CONTINUALLY. TO GET A
BILL THAT WE ARE ALL COMFORTABLE
WITHIN IT WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
THAT.
NIGHT AND THE CHURCH RECOMMEND I
TAKE THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS AND I JUST WANT TO
REMIND YOU MISTER QUIRK SITS TO
THE LEFT OF YOU.
AND I SIT IN FRONT OF YOU
[inaudible]
YES SIR.
ON AB ELEVEN TWENTY ONE THE
MISSION IS DUE PASSAGE
APPROPRIATIONS JONES SAWYER TO
ANSWER I LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE BARRICADE HAND I CAN
I DEEP.
DEEP I KAMLAGER-DOVE.
QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
SAN DIEGO I WICKS WICKS I THE
MEASURE PASSES THANK YOU YOU.
AND LAST BILL FOR THE DAY.
MISTER LACKEY [inaudible]
VICE CHAIR.
I MOVE THE BILL WAS CHAIRMAN
[inaudible]
I'LL SECOND [inaudible]
WELL.
I DON'T KNOW AB.
FOURTEEN FIFTY ITEM [inaudible]
TWENTY TWO NO I'M NOT.
BUT YOU KNOW.
MIGHT AS WELL CHECK.
WELL THANK YOU CHAIR -- BEFORE I
BEGIN I WOULD LIKE TO THINK.
MY WITNESSES -- THEY TRAVELS
FOUR HUNDRED MILES AND NOT ONLY
DO THEY DO THAT.
BUT THEY'VE BEEN WAITING ALL DAY.
SO VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THEIR
INDULGENCE IN IT SHOWS THERE --
COMMITMENT TO THIS ISSUE.
AND AS YOU KNOW AS YOU CAN READ
I'M PRESENTING AB.
FOURTEEN FIFTY THIS BILL CALLS
ON THE COUNTIES BY TWENTY THIRTY
TO FILE REQUIRED PAPERWORK. FOR
SUSPECTED CHILD ABUSE
ELECTRONICALLY.
THESE FORMS ARE ALREADY MANDATED
BY LAW BUT THIS BILL WOULD TAKE
THE FORM TO MAKE THEM AVAILABLE
AS ELECTRONIC VERSIONS.
WITH QUICK INACCURATE
TRANSMISSION BETWEEN LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AND CHILD
WELFARE SERVICES.
THE CLAIMS THAT WOULD REMAIN ON
THE DATABASE WOULD BE THOSE
REPORTS THAT WERE SUBSTANTIATED
[inaudible]
EMPHASIZE THAT.
WE'RE SUBSTANTIATE REPORTS WOULD
NOT INCLUDE THOSE THAT WERE NOT.
THIS ACTUAL ENSURE THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT CHILD WELFARE
AGENCIES.
AND COUNTY DA OFFICES AREN'T
BECAUSE SECURITY CATION WHEN
INVESTIGATING CLAIMS OF CHILD
ABUSE.
THIS BILL AS A DIRECT RESULT
FROM THE TRAGIC DEATH OF EIGHT
YEAR OLD.
GABRIEL FERNANDEZ WHO WAS
REPEATEDLY BEATEN.
TORTURED AND EVENTUALLY KILLED
BY HIS MOTHER AND HER BOYFRIEND.
WHAT GAMER WAS FOUNDED FINALLY
BROUGHT INTO THE HOSPITAL IT WAS
ALREADY TOO LATE?
HIS BODY WAS RIDDLED WITH BB GUN
PELLETS CAT FECES IN HIS THROAT.
CIGARETTE BURNS ON HIS FACE AND
BODY.
A FRACTURE IN HIS SKULL.
ACCOUNT WAS OTHER INJURES WERE
FOUND IN HIS BODY.
THIS HORRIFIC CIRCUMSTANCE IS
WHEN THAT HAPPENS ALL TOO OFTEN.
ESPECIALLY AMONGST RURAL REGIONS.
WITH MANY CHILDREN MOVING IN AND
OUT OF THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM.
CHILDREN IN THESE SITUATIONS DO
NOT HAVE TO BE ALONE.
LA COUNTY IS CREATED AN ONLINE
DATABASE CALL THE SCARS. TO
SPEED UP THE COMMUNICATION
PROCESS THIS ELECTRONIC SYSTEM
WILL ENSURE THE TIMELY
TRANSFERRING.
OF INFORMATION ACROSS STATE
AGENCIES.
THAT'S MANDATED PAPER FORM.
HAS BEEN IN STATUTE FOR MANY
YEARS.
THIS BILL AB FORTY FIFTY UPDATES
THE REPORTING REQUIREMENT TO
TRANSMIT INFORMATION MORE
QUICKLY AND EFFICIENTLY BY
UTILIZING TODAY'S TECHNOLOGIES.
THE BILL REQUIRES THE COUNTIES
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AND CHILD
WHERE FOR WELFARE AGENCIES TO DO
THEIR DO JAIL DILIGENCE WHEN
REPORTING CASES OF ALLEGED ABUSE.
AND MAKE SURE THAT CHILDREN ARE
SAFE S A CAMPY.
SO WITH ME TODAY IS EMILY
CARRANZA.
GEHRELS COUSIN AS WELL AS WENDY
FROM THE NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
BASED IN THE OTTAWA VALLEY SALVA.
HELLO I'M VICTOR RAILS AT I'LL
BEAT REPRESENTING SOLVE ON AS
WELL MISS -- TWENTY THREE HE'LL
BE TRANSLATING FOR OKAY.
YOU MAY BEGIN.
WHEN I HAVE NO CHOICE?
GOOD EVENING NUMBER TWENTY TWO
HERE MY NAME IS WENDY THREE
HE'LL ANYMORE SAID THAT THE
OTHER THAN VIOLENCE LOOK BACK
WE'VE COME HERE FROM THE OF THE
ANTELOPE VALLEY.
ACCEPT THEM INTO A LESS TO AYE
LANCASTER.
AND THE CITY AND LANCASTER.
MANY MOST ME COMPANION -- CEO.
ME AND MY COLLEAGUES COME ARC
CAME HERE TODAY THE PERCENT
ALONG A COMPLETE OUT COMPLETE
THE TO REPRESENT OUR COMMUNITY I
AM MOST FREEDOM LAST CAME WILL
COLLECT A LOCAL DILLON AT THE
CASINOS.
AMIGOS E. LESS ESCUELAS IN
CANADA.
WE HAVE SIGNATURES OF SCHOOLS
AND PEOPLE WITHIN OUR COMMUNITY.
FOCUSED ALMOST ALL OF THE THE
END OF QUE QUE CENTERS IN A LOT
FOR YOU BUT I IS THE LATE BUT I
GUESS THAT IS THE LAKE PLACID
IMPLEMENT THAT -- ASKING FOR
YOUR SUPPORT SO THIS -- BILL
COULD BE IT COULD PASS MAYBE
THEY'RE GONNA TESTIMONY THAT.
YEAH I'M WITH.
ELECTED TO THE NINOS FOR MANY
CANCERS PHYSICAL MET THEM. FOR
FOR CASTLE CAN ALSO REST WELDING
PORTABLE STUFF UNITS CAN LOOK UP
WITH SEVEN WHICH OTHERS AT THE
END OKAY -- DUE TO OUR CHAO
NEGLIGENCE -- INNOCENT LIVES ARE
WE'RE LOSING INNOCENT LIVES.
THE THING WITH THAT BUT I MEAN
YOU CAN PUT ON PHYSICAL MENTAL
STRUGGLE I HAVE THREE CHILDREN --
PHYSICALLY PHYSICALLY ABUSED
SACRAMENTO SOUTH SEXUALLY ABUSED
BUT I STILL SEVEN OF THESE -- TO
DESTROY THEIR LITTLE LIVES THERE
MAY BE A LEAD OF HIS YOUNGER
SYSTEM I NIKON MEDIA NO FOUR
PROJECT -- IN MY CASE AT THE
SYSTEM DID NOT WORK FOR MY
FAMILY IT DESTROYED THEM.
ON THE COMPUTER MUCH PROGRAM OF
MENTORING OUT OKAY LASSES DAY.
THEN THE NEWS WHEN I WAS
FINISHED WITH ONE OF MY
REQUIREMENTS -- OUR FAMILY WAS
BROKEN APART.
LESS WELL AFTER THE WHOLE AND
SEES THEM MY MUSICAL BENEFITS AS
WELL AS GO ON IS THAT GOING TO
USE THE PHONE.
THE THOSE SEQUELS THAT ARE GONNA
SCAR MY KIDS IT'S GOING TO BE
FOR FOR LIFE YOU GENERAL.
NEW YORK OF WITH A COFFEE AT
THEY'RE NOT GONNA BE CHILDREN
THERE'LL BE ABLE TO COME.
FIVE BUT I MEAN I'M IS QUITE
OFTEN WHEN I MADE THAT CAN HAVE
A REGULAR SCHOOL LIFE OKAY HAS
BEEN SENT CONTROLS AND DONE WITH
MINE BECAUSE THEY THINK
EVERYBODY'S BAD.
WHAT CAN NO SENATE THANK YOU
BECAUSE THEY WERE PROTECTED?
LIST OF BECOME MOST KAMEL.
INTENT IS WHAT WE PLEASE WE PLAY
AND WE ASK YOU AS
REPRESENTATIVES.
FROM YOU CALL MY MOST.
BY THAT IS AS FAR AS PARENTS AND
AS HUMAN BEING.
ACCUSED.
DISAGREE COMES BEFORE WORKS WELL
FOR YOU WE ASK AND WE PLEASE.
FOR YOUR SUPPORT AT THE AMERICAN
PORTENT IS VERY IMPORTANT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING HI MY NAME IS EMILY
CROWNS I AM THE COUSIN OF GABLE
FERNANDES UM AND THE REASON I'M
HERE TODAY IS. TO PLEASE THE
ABOUT THE A. B. FOURTEEN FIFTY
LAW FOR CABLES LAW. TO CONSIDER
IT DEEPLY. FOR WHAT HE SUFFERED
WHAT HE WENT THROUGH.
IT'S VERY HARD FOR ME RIGHT NOW --
I JUST FEEL THAT YOU KNOW IF
THERE'S A BETTER COMMUNICATION
TO AGENCIES AND LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND THINGS THAT ARE IN PLACE.
FOR THESE CHILDREN THAT NO
LONGER HAVE A VOICE AND FOR THE
CHILDREN THAT ARE CURRENTLY
GOING THROUGH ABUSE AND NOBODY'S
LISTENING TO THEM.
I MEAN IT IT WOULD HELP A LOT
YOU KNOW I MEAN.
IT'S JUST.
IT'S BEEN A HARD SIX YEARS TO
GET THROUGH.
AND WE'RE JUST HOPING THAT
SOMETHING CAN FINALLY BE DONE IN
THAT.
YOU KNOW YOU GUYS WOULD REALLY
DEEPLY CONSIDER THIS.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I'M SORRY ANY OPPOSITION.
WOULD YOU MIND [inaudible]
OR IF.
GOOD EVENING KATHY SURE ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA.
I WANT TO START BY ACKNOWLEDGING
THE TRAGEDY OF THE DEATH OF
GABRIEL FERNANDEZ -- IT WAS A
TRAGIC EVENT -- AND I THINK THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA -- AND ALL
OF US NEEDS TO FIGURE OUT WAYS
TO BETTER PROTECT OUR CHILDREN
IN THE FUTURE THAT THAT IS A
GOAL THAT WE CERTAINLY ALL SHARE --
THAT SAID -- THE CHANGES
PROPOSED IN AB FOURTEEN FIFTY
WOULD NOT HAVE PREVENTED
GABRIEL'S DEATH WHAT HAPPENED
AFTER ALLEGATIONS OF ABUSE HAD
BEEN INVESTIGATED AND DETERMINED
TO BE UNFOUNDED.
AND HAPPENED IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY WHERE THEY ALREADY HAD AN
ONLINE DATABASE SUCH AS WOULD BE
REQUIRED UNDER THIS BILL.
AB FOURTEEN FIFTY PROPOSES
CHANGES THAT WOULD PUT ALL
CALIFORNIANS AT RISK OF HAVING
CHILD ABUSE IS ALLEGATIONS
AGAINST THEM.
ENTERED INTO A DATABASE WITH
LITTLE OR NO OVERSIGHT AS TO HOW
THE INFORMATION CAN BE ACCESSED
ARE USED.
AND WITH UNDEFINED STANDARDS AND
PROCEDURES FOR THE REMOVAL OF
INFORMATION I WANT TO NOTE IN
PARTICULAR -- THAT ALTHOUGH THE
BILL SAYS THAT ONLY
SUBSTANTIATED ALLEGATIONS WILL
REMAIN ON ON THE IN THE DATABASE
FOR OUR HOUSE SUBSTANTIATED
WOULD BE DETERMINED.
THE CREATION OF A GOVERNMENT
DATABASE TO COLLECT UNTESTED
ACCUSATIONS IF IT IS TO BE DONE
AT ALL.
REQUIRES THE UTMOST CARE IN
SETTING STANDARDS AS TO HOW THE
INFORMATION COMES TO BE INCLUDED
IN THE DATABASE.
HOW THE INFORMATION MAY BE USED
WHEN IT SHOULD NO LONGER BE
RETAINED AND WHAT THE PROCEDURES
ARE FOR CHALLENGING THE
INCLUSION OF THE INFORMATION?
WE'VE SEEN THE TYPES OF ABUSES
THAT OCCURED WHEN SUCH STANDARDS
ARE NOT EXPRESSLY AND
SPECIFICALLY LAID OUT.
WE'VE SEEN IT WITH THE STATEWIDE
CHILD ABUSE CENTRAL INDEX WHICH
FOR MANY YEARS INCLUDED THE
NAMES OF MANY WRONGFULLY ACCUSED
PEOPLE AND GAVE THEM NO WAY TO
GET THEIR NAMES OFF OF THAT LIST.
WE'VE ALSO SEEN IT WITH CAL GANG
WHICH ALSO KEPT INFORMATION ON
PERSONS WHO DID NOT BELONG IN
THE SYSTEM AND ALLOW THE
INFORMATION TO BE USED IN WAYS
THAT WERE NOT AUTHORIZED.
YET AB FOURTEEN FIFTY REQUIRES
EACH OF CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES TO SET UP SUCH A
DATABASE.
AND FOR THE MOST PART LETS THEM
SET THEIR OWN STANDARDS AS TO
HOW THEY WILL OPERATE.
THE POTENTIAL FOR ABUSE AND
INDEED THE LIKELIHOOD OF ABUSE
IS CLEAR.
WE ASK YOU TO PROTECT THE CAT
RIGHTS OF ALL CALIFORNIANS BY
VOTING NO ON THIS BILL WE ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ARE THERE ANY -- QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MISS REBEKAH.
OUR QUE HAN -- MISTER LACKEY CAN
YOU SPEAK TO WHETHER YOU'D BE
WILLING.
TO HAVE.
AMEND THE BILL TO INCLUDE ANY
SORT OF HAM ANY OF THE THINGS
THAT THE ACLU HAS MENTIONED
ABOUT.
GIVING GUIDELINES TO THE
COUNTIES AS THEY MOVE FORWARD.
CERTAINLY WOULD BE WILLING TO
WORK WITH.
WITH MAKING SURE THAT THERE ARE
SUFFICIENT GUIDELINES TO PROTECT
THE CONCERNS YOU JUST VOICED.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
THE CLOSENESS LACKEY.
I JUST ASKED THAT THIS COMMITTEE
WOULD BE THOUGHTFUL AND REALIZE
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE NOT
JUST PROTECT CHILDREN.
BY BRINGING THIS COMMUNICATION
COMMUNICATION IS WHERE THE
BREAKDOWN IS HAPPENING ON THESE --
THESE TRAGIC CIRCUMSTANCES AND
WE JUST WANT TO FACILITATE BY
USING TECHNOLOGY.
AND ALLOWING THE COOPERATION
BETWEEN WHEN WHEN YOU'RE BEING
WATCHED YOU'RE ALWAYS BETTER.
AND I THINK THAT THAT IS WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO FACILITATE
MISCOMMUNICATION AND FAIR.
INTERACTION BETWEEN THOSE
RESPONSIBLE FOR PROTECTING
CHILDREN.
THANK YOU.
AND I MEAN IT IT.
LET ME START WITH MAKING SURE I
KNOW.
DO YOU DO PROPONENTS BROUGHT
SOME CARDS I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE
HIM SUBMITTED.
IF YOU DON'T MIND. FOR THE
RECORD SIR TO BE WE HAVE ALL
THAT BECAUSE WE DO WANT TO HEAR
FROM MR LACKEYS COMMUNITY LAWYER
FROM YOUR COMMUNITY.
I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT WE WE DO
CARE.
IF YOU NEED.
TO TRANSLATED -- THAT THAT BE
FINE TOO BUT TO MAKE HER
UNDERSTAND THAT -- JUST
COMMITTEE DOES GENERALLY CARE.
AND WITH WITH THAT IN MIND I
ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE.
THAT WE GET. TO THE ROOT.
OF THE PROBLEM BECAUSE I I'VE
ALWAYS HAD -- ISSUES.
WHEN?
GOVERNMENT BREAKS DOWN.
AND THEN WE TRY TO COME UP WITH
A SOLUTION THAT MAY NOT ACTUALLY
ADDRESS.
FIXING IT.
BECAUSE IT SOUNDS LIKE IT WAS.
IN THIS CASE IT WAS REPORTED.
AND IGNORED OR NOT TAKEN
SERIOUSLY [inaudible]
BY.
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES IN.
YOUR COMMUNITY THAT SHOULD OF
AND WEATHER IS A DATABASE OR NOT
I'M NOT SURE WOULD HAVE.
IT WOULD HAVE HELPED IF IF.
THE INFORMATION IS GIVEN.
TO OF THE APPROPRIATE WAS SOCIAL
WORKERS.
OR IS LAW ENFORCEMENT.
WHAT IS ON SCHOOL DISTRICTS --
WE ALL KNOW.
PERSONALLY BECAUSE WE HAVE
COLLEAGUES THAT.
HAVE BEEN REPORTED FOR THAT AND
AND THEY ACTED SWIFTLY.
LIKE THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO AN
EIGHT DID WHAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED
TO DO [inaudible]
AND OF HOPEFULLY IT ALL WORKS
OUT FOR EVERYONE.
AND PROTECTING CHILDREN -- SEEMS
LIKE.
THE HORRENDOUS THINGS THAT --
THAT WERE HAPPENING TO THIS
YOUNG MAN IS -- UNCONSCIONABLE
AND I A MY REAL CONCERN IS HOW
DO YOU FIX.
THAT SYSTEM WHERE IN ONE PART OF
JUST OF THE STATE.
THEY ACTED REALLY QUICKLY.
AND IN ANOTHER PART OF STATE.
SOME AGAIN DO ANYTHING
[inaudible]
AND AND THE CONCERNS OF THE ACLU
IS REALLY IMPORTANT -- THAT.
THESE DATABASES DON'T TURN INTO
SOMETHING.
THAT I DON'T THINK YOU WANT.
RIGHT WHERE WERE YOU TRYING TO
GET [inaudible]
TO AND I'M I'M TRYING TO FIND A
WAY [inaudible] TWO TO SATISFY.
THE ACLU IS CONCERNED.
BUT ALSO MAKE SURE THAT -- THIS
IS EXISTING SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE
NOW FROM THE DOJ.
AND AND OTHERS DOES LA COUNTY
WORK WELL WHAT IS IT WORK BETTER
THAN.
WHY DIDN'T WORK IN YOUR AREA
BECAUSE YOU'RE YOU'RE PARTLY
COUNTER?
WHY DIDN'T WORK THERE IN A MAY
WORK SOMEWHERE ELSE WHICH IS A
REAL CONCERN IT'S WORKING THERE
NOW?
RIGHT I I APPRECIATE YOU MADE
SURE OF WORKING THERE NOW MR
LACKEY -- AND SO OF I ALWAYS
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE MAKE SURE
THAT THE SYSTEM WORKS AND WE
DON'T CREATE REDUNDANT SYSTEMS.
THAT REALLY DOESN'T.
ADDRESS WHAT'S GOING ON I WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE A SUGGESTION BUT I
DON'T KNOW.
IF IT IF IT WILL IF IT WILL HELP.
FOR IF I CAN GET THE ACLU. TO TO
ALSO WORK WITH US. TO TO ENSURE
THAT WHEN SOMETHING'S WORK WHEN
SOMETHING'S REPORTED.
THAT IT.
GETS TO WHAT YOU WANT MAKING
SURE WE PROTECT OUR CHILDREN.
AND HOPEFULLY USING EXISTING
DATABASE OR THE ONE IN THE
COUNTY.
BUT MORE IMPORTANT IF YOU CAN
TELL ME WHY IS WORKING NOW.
AS A AS OPPOSED TO THEN HOW WE
CAN STRENGTHEN BUT WE HAVE NOW --
BUT THAT MAY BE MEAN.
NOT VOTING FOR IT NOW BUT ASKING
FOR RECONSIDERATION AND GIVING
ME [inaudible]
AND YOU.
THE FAMILY AND THE COMMITTEE. TO
WORK ON THIS ALL AWAY. TO THE
END OF THE YEAR. TO HOPEFULLY
COME UP WITH SOMETHING.
THAT TRULY MAKES THAT TRULY WILL.
WE'LL GET THIS DONE.
AND AND I TRULY MEAN THAT I MEAN
I FELT.
I FEEL EVERYTHING THAT THEY SAID.
AND I TRULY WANT TO FIGURE THIS
OUT AND AND I KNOW YOU'VE TRIED
THIS.
ONCE BEFORE AND I THINK WHAT WE
MAY BE TALKING ABOUT THE WRONG
THING.
AND WE MAY NEED TO GET.
TO THE CENTER OF IT AND SO I AM
GOING TO ASK. FOR THE COMMITTEE
TO TO TO VOTE NO I KNOW.
SOME OR HAVE SOME HARD TIME IF
THEY WANT TO DO THAT BUT ALSO
MUCH AS FOR RECONSIDERATION.
SO THAT I CAN WORK WITH YOU AND
I CAN MAKE PERSONAL COMMITMENT
TO YOU.
THAT WE COME UP WITH SOME
SOLUTION.
THAT IS A TRUE SOLUTION. TO
RESOLVING THAT SO THAT
[inaudible]
WE LOWER.
AND HOPEFULLY ELIMINATE.
AT THIS EVER HAPPENS AGAIN. TO
ANY OF THESE FAMILIES NOW IN
YOUR COMMUNITY BUT IN MINE.
THE CITY HERE NOW.
SO WITH THAT THE CHURCH FRONT
REGRETTABLY -- RECOMMENDING A NO
VOTE.
ON AB FOURTEEN FIFTY THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER NO LACKEY.
LACKEY I BAUER-KAHAN.
BAUER-KAHAN I DEEP [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
QUIRK NO QUIRK NOW SANTIAGO.
AND THERE WERE NO WICKS.
WICKS NOW.
YOU'RE ASKING FOR
RECONSIDERATION.
AND SO TO THE FAMILY.
IN.
TWO I'M I'M PERSONALLY MAKING A
PERSONAL COMMITMENT TO WORK
PERMITS TO LACKEY TO COME OR
SOLUTION.
AND WILL HAVE SOMETHING FOR YOU
HOPEFULLY.
IT GETS EVERYBODY TOGETHER TO
GET US TO WHERE WE WANT SO IT
DOESN'T HAPPEN AGAIN.
BUT I PROMISE YOU THERE WILL BE
ONE I HOPE THAT YOU LIKE.
AND THAT YOU FEEL COMFORTABLE
WITH IT.
AND HOPE THAT MR LACKEY CAN
SUPPORT.
BECAUSE IF HE IS THE AUTHOR HE
IS.
THE DRIVER OF THIS.
WE'LL GIVE IT OUR BEST.
NETWORK GET SOMETHING DONE.
BY UNANIMOUS CONSENT.
WE'RE GOING TO GRANT
RECONSIDERATION THANK YOU.
HEY WHAT'S THAT IT.
NOW WE HAVE TO DO EVERYTHING
THAT WAS ON OUR GOING TO DO
EVERYTHING THAT WAS ON CALL.
WHICH IS ALMOST EVERYTHING
[inaudible]
HAVE ANOTHER.
WE ALREADY I ALREADY.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
BARRICADE HAN BARRICADE HAD AYE
QUIRK [inaudible]
THE SECOND [inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I WICKS WICKS I CAN
THINK HUNTERS ADOPTED.
I DON'T NUMBER ONE AB THREE
NINETY TWO BARRA CAM BARRICADE
HAD I ITEM NUMBER TWO AB
EIGHTEEN THIS MEASURE WAS ON
CALL.
BARRICADE HAND BARRICADE HAD AYE
QUIRK.
QUIRK NO SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO AYE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB THREE OH
THREE WAS ON CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER.
FOUR AB SIX FIFTY SIX THIS
MEASURE WAS ON CALL LACKEY NO
LACKEY NO BARRICADE HAND.
BAUER-KAHAN I DEEP [inaudible]
QUIRK.
QUIRK I SANTIAGO.
SAN DIEGO I WICKS.
WICKS I THAT MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR EXCUSE ME FIVE
EIGHTY SIX NINETY WHEN THIS
MEASURE WAS ON CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER SIX EIGHTY SEVEN NO
ONE WAS ON CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER -- SEVEN EIGHTY
SEVEN TO THIS MEASURE WAS ON
CALLED BAUER-KAHAN BARRICADE HAD
AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I
WICKS WICKS I THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
ITEM NUMBER NINE AB EIGHT EIGHT
FOUR THIS MEASURE WAS ON CALL
[inaudible]
QUIRK.
QUIRK NOW SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO NOT VOTING WICKS WICKS
KNOW THAT MEASURE FAILS.
YOU CERTAINLY MAY CERTAINLY MAY
[inaudible]
REGRETTING IT.
BY UNANIMOUS CONSENT.
ON AB AIRPORT RECONSIDERATION
WAS GOOD GRANTED BY UNANIMOUS
CONSENT.
I DON'T NUMBER NINETY NINE OF
FOUR WAS PULLED BY THE AUTHOR.
ITEM NUMBER. TEN EIGHTY TEN
SIXTY FOURTH THIS MEASURE WAS ON
CALL SANTIAGO.
ITEM NUMBER TEN EIGHTY TEN SIXTY
FOUR BY A MEMBER RUMORED SU CHI.
SANTIAGO I THAT MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN WAS JUST
DISPENSED WITH.
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AB ELEVEN
SEVENTY WAS ON CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN AB TWELVE
EIGHTY TWO BY SOME MEMBER KALRA
THIS MEASURE WAS ON CALL LACKEY.
LACKEY NO BARRICADE HAND
BARRICADE HAD AYE DEEP.
QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I WICKS WICKS I THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN AB TWELVE
NINETY FOUR THIS MEASURE WAS ON
CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN AB THIRTEEN
TWENTY ONE THIS MEASURE WAS ON
CALL [inaudible]
DEEP [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE OF QUIRK.
HI QUIRK I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I THAT MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN AB THIRTEEN
FORTY EIGHT WAS ON CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN AB
THIRTEEN NINETY THIS MEASURE WAS
ON CALL BAUER-KAHAN.
BAUER-KAHAN I DEEP.
QUIRK FIVE QUIRK I SANTIAGO.
ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN AB
[inaudible]
THIRTEEN NINETY YES.
ON A. B. THIRTEEN NINETY
SANTIAGO I WICKS WICKS I THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN AB FOURTEEN
OH FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GLORIA THIS MEASURE WHAT'S ON
CALL BACK BAUER-KAHAN.
BAUER-KAHAN I DEEP.
QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I THAT MEASURE PASSES.
I DON'T NUMBER NINETEEN AB
FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE THIS
MEASURE WAS ON CALL BAUER-KAHAN.
BAUER-KAHAN HI.
QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I THAT MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM TWENTY EIGHTY FOURTEEN
THIRTY FIVE WITH ON CONSENT.
ITEM TWENTY ONE AB FOURTEEN
FORTY NINE BY SOME MEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA QUIRK.
AYE QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
SAN DIEGO I WICKS.
WICKS I THAT MEASURE
[inaudible]
OUT.
ITEM NUMBER AT TWENTY TWO WAS
JUST DISPENSED WITH ITEM TWENTY
THREE FOURTEEN NINETY THREE WAS
ON CONSENT.
ITEM TWENTY FOUR FOURTEEN EIGHTY
SIX WAS ON CONSENT.
ITEM TWENTY FIVE AB FIFTEEN OH
ONE THIS MEASURE WAS ON CALL
DEEP [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
QUIRK.
QUIRK NOT VOTING SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
WICKS.
WICKS I THAT MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SIX WAS
HOLDING AND COMMITTEE.
ITEM TWENTY SEVEN AB. FIFTEEN
NINETY EIGHT WITH POLL BY THE
AUTHOR.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY
SIXTEEN HUNDRED BY SOMEONE
NUMBER KALRA DEEP [inaudible]
QUIRK.
HI QUIRK I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I
WICKS WICKS I THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
ITEM TWENTY NINE AB SIXTEEN OH
THREE WAS ON CONSENT.
ITEM THIRTY THIS MEASURE WAS ON
CALL AB SIXTEEN THIRTY SIX QUIRK
HI QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
SAN DIEGO I THAT MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM THIRTY ONE HAS BEEN
DISPENSED WITH.
I THIRTY TWO A. B. SIXTEEN SIXTY
NINE THIS MEASURE WAS ON CALL
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
QUIRK HI [inaudible]
QUIRK I BAUER-KAHAN SORRY I
BARRICADE HAD I MY APOLOGIES
MISS CAMP.
AT SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I THAT BILL PASSES.
ITEM THIRTY THREE AB SEVENTEEN
FORTY SEVEN THIS MEASURE WAS ON
CALL.
BACK BAUER-KAHAN BAUER-KAHAN I
QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO AYE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM THIRTY FOUR AB SEVENTEEN
NINETY FOUR WAS ON CONSENT.
I WANT TO THANK COMMITTEE FOR
TEN AND A HALF HOURS -- ADDED ON
OKAY.
WITH THAT ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
PUBLIC SAFETY STAND A PUBLIC
SAFETY STANDS ADJOURNED
[inaudible]
YEAH